Oh
I'm like a hell now my sister's still
wearing your animals and wonder
what to draw and this bitch got on a big
bra with the buckles on the back so when
I saw her I just I just hit the bitch
out like pow I just start beating her
and I'm your host Roy Wood jr. we all
have that special woman in our life the
one we like to put up on a pedestal
finger sandwiches boy oh thank you mom
go little walk
make it rain
[Applause]
now make sure you separate the ones from
the five no no I gotta pick up some
money if it's my boy
[Music]
I was a senior I never forget it senior
year last week of school I didn't even
have school
I'm just running around visiting other
that day school Webster
high school with my best friend I'm up
there with Vani I'm like girl I'm coming
up to your school while I'm getting
myself prepared for college cuz I'm
letting y'all know right now at that
point I was going art school I knew it
in my mind I had applied I was just
waiting to get me a scholarship had my
little 16 pieces gathered for my
portfolio review I'm ready for my
sounds like I'm done I did my thing I'm
visiting I don't need no
more grades so I'm thinking I'm cute you
know ideas back in the eighties
everybody wardrobe they pinky on your
mouth I'm walking around next thing I
know I'm at another school all I hear is
damn name
I said no women that do not oh that's my
mama and I look and her ass is sweeping
up the hallway up he runs the school
right I didn't know it was a janitor I
know she had these skills I see them
five years so now I'm like almost he not
talking to me in front of my
friends sweeping up the school so I'm
just walking she's about I know you hear
me calling you and it's your mama I was
like oh Lord
now you know our kids are you in there
I'm like I didn't even know you was back
oh I love you I missed you how you being
with you dude and I was standing there
like okay hurry up with this and she's
telling I'm telling her I'm about to go
to college she don't know none of this
she ain't seen me in five years I'm
telling I'm about to go to college got
my little portfolio together she turned
my oh I want to see it you should bring
it up to me bring it to where I live I
don't know where the you live
give me the address I'm gonna bring in
and leave me alone cuz you know I'm
walking like this get away from me and
my friends so I go home I tell my father
he upset cuz we didn't know where else
is back in Missouri and I was like i'ma
go on and take it to her so she can see
that I'm you know trying to do something
positive so he's like well let me see
the address so I let him see the address
and it was in this new little project
area they had just built anything good
they tore down these one projects and
built these new townhouse so my father
saw the address he was a little
reluctant let me drive his car so I was
like let me go and take you down
I called my cousin Linda that's my
ride-or-die we ride down here I was like
let me go and take this down so my mama
can see it and leave me the alone
so we get out a knock on the door some
big burly ass woman come to the door
this bitch looking crazy she's like I
gotta help you I was like yeah I'm here
to see Dale my mother told me to bring
she like oh yeah come on in
so I walk in is like nine grown bitches
just standing around drinking smoking
listening to Marvin Gaye and I'm
here my cousin we trying to spruce
nudies my brothers you know you feeling
like your germs are so my mother comes
dashing down the steps
cuz she all proud now I'm in the door
out and showed up with my portfolio she
all coming down the steps want me to lay
it out and show everybody she just
bragging who and my baby did this and
she drew daddy and that's a
self-portrait and my baby didn't I'm
thinking to myself it's you help me do
nothing they cannot hurry up with this
I gotta get my daddy car back
so you know she's like well I'm gonna
take and I'm gonna keep it I was like
mom you cannot keep my portfolio down
here well you can come pick it up for my
school I want to show sue and suicune
and so so me trying not to argue with
our ass I leave my portfolio with her
because I got to get the up out
this area lo and behold next day I get a
phone call from my little sister she's
11 at the time I'm like 17 she's on the
phone crying talking about come down
here and get me because make at door -
Chrissy jump tell me I'm like who the
is Chrissy so I get down there me
and Linda cuz you know I'm called my
cousin we get down there
this big-ass 14 year old bitch she got
titties like she 20 for fighting my
11 year old sister this
business I'm like hell no my sister
still wearing your animal isn't
wonder what y'all and these bees got on
a big bra with the buckles on the back
so when I saw her
I just I just hit the bitch up like pow
I just start beating her and I bet you
too big to be jumping on my little ass
sister
I was whooping her ass sounds like
that I told my sister get your get
in the car let's go so I took her back
to my daddy house I called her daddy he
came and got her
next thing I know my mother calls over
to my father house uh I don't know what
the you think you do it coming down
here jumping on with yo
grown-ass self I said mama that girl
jumped on your daughter and she too big
to be trying to fight you I don't know
but I know one thing you
better come down here and get your
portfolio bitch you know
back in the day where you can't believe
some you look at the phone an old
school phone like I'm looking at the
phone like my mama did not just call me
a bitch call me a bitch you got me that
ice okay I got it
boom you know who I'm calling my
cousin Linda live up the
street I said cuz we ran down you get my
portfolio let's go cuz I know my mama
ten minutes later I'm down here in front
of a cathouse it's all the lights out
it's serene it's quiet and I'm
looking nervous don't be quiet in
the project I don't get I knew
they are and I'm like waiting I know
Lysa
so I'm knocking on the door ain't nobody
open the door so me as I understanding
there we bang it nobody opens the door
next thing I hear the mother
window raise up on the second floor my
mama's gonna lean out ah you ain't
welcome down this cuz you
too grown to do the you did you
up my situation you got somewhere
to stay I ain't got no
where the stake and you come down here
causing trouble so take your
portfolio and she just
start tossing my out the window one
by one one picture one P my just
floating down like a kite with no wind
just hidden
and I'm in amazing like notice
bitches not throwing my portfolio
pictures my paintings my every
thing out the window
then she tossed the whole
leather case out there so they hit the
ground I'm trying to pick my up
next thing you know make ad runs out
this bitch I'm out and this foot jumping
oh my mother daughter and the
bitch just start stepping all on my
self-portrait it's all up now I'm
crying and I'm mad we had two quarters
me and my cousin Linda we went to the
payphone up the street we
call all nine her sisters with one
quarter
gee everybody knows my name punky Jeanne
Lynn and Z Rhonda tisha cousin when we
use other part of the cloth some other
mother cousin waited at the
payphone gene rolled up two cars of
we roll right up in front
of that
my cousin Jean got out the car first she
went up there boom boom boom
I don't even know who answered the door
because whoever they called it
first gene snatched them up for
everybody
we all we coming out of nowhere now
people running out the house we fighting
like a I was like this
and my mama she don't want to come out
cuz she embarrassed but then her friends
start getting up
so she had to come out help so we
thought her up cuz you are
you're helping your friends that me
up and I'm your daughter so now we just
might have been on 10 15 minutes
somebody called the police
somebody called the police paddy where I
could come to um they take this half
they take me my cousin's all of us we
down with the police
station just all in the big rumble they
want to know what's going on I ain't in
that station I let me see my
portfolio and then they
could understand what had to go down so
they let her body go they couldn't let
me go cuz I'm a miner and they want to
release me to a parent and my dumbass
mama time up oh I'm right here I get a
release
I know if I did you you wouldn't reason
why's he here ain't nobody gonna release
her to you Oh like I had to wait on my
daddy and I'm like oh I don't even
know I'm explaining to my father so my
father comes and giving me I'm all
crying I'm mad I don't even know what to
do cuz all I can think in the back of my
mind is I'm not gonna get into college
because my portfolio is up
I got a review and a week I don't even
know what I'm gonna tell these people
I'm just like maybe I'm just
gonna be working at UPS I ain't no
gettin up so when my dad picked
me up I thought he was gonna be mad
angry didn't even say and when a
person don't say none you don't know
what's on their mind or what they think
it you really start to be nervous cuz I
like to hear him saying I told you not
to take your heads down there you know
your momma sold off all that I
didn't want to hear that he didn't say
soon as we got in house he said let
me see your portfolio and he laid it out
on the kitchen table he was like you
know what I'm gonna help you get your
together we gonna work it out
my daddy helped me tape up my pictures
we was fixing touching up he's
like you're gonna get that damn
scholarship cuz I ain't got it go get it
and I'm thinking to myself I am NOT
going to this portfolio review with my
looking like this but he made me go
my father made me go he took me I was
like oh god I'm nervous
I get out I'm sitting in the hallway I
got my portfolio they called me into the
room for white people in there I'm
standing there like oh Lord some nigga
when they see my portfolio all
up this is more than the dog ate
the homework I can't even say no
like that
so I'm maybe has a little easel you know
for you to bring your out hole
opened up my I pulled out my
self-portrait I just want with the
big-ass footprint on it right on my
right
so I just set it up on the thing I would
they didn't even give me an opportunity
to explain they say can you just step
out in the hallway for a second
nah man like whoa what the so I'm
sitting in the hallway talking to my dad
you know how you're nervous you're not
sure what's going on I'm just sitting
there like what the they takin
forever they're not asking me should I'm
just in the hallway the lady comes out
about 20 minutes later gives me my
portfolio back and she said we'll be in
touch with you so now I'm riding home
like what the do that mean you know
questions they probably looked at my
like we ain't got time for this
nigga they made me sit out here for
no reason so now I'm really angry I'm
thinking of all kind of ways I can get
back at my mama I was like i'ma call up
to her job like that I'm getting a
bitch fire she got three IDs she ain't
got no GED she awfully I'm like and she
bring it on pile of paper from the
school I was thinking all kind of
to get her as hired about a month later
I got a letter in the mail from
Fontbonne college and it said I got a
partial scholarship I ain't even see the
word partial all I saw the scholarship
on the I don't know what it
was but I was so I was like oh
I got in now I failed to mention
that I have always been a scrapbooker I
love to scrapbook about my since fourth
grade so I copy every thing even
today I was like oh give me a copy of
these papers I need a copy of everything
so I copied everything I keep everything
when I got that letter I wrote on that
letter I got in bitch
and I'm melting my to make at
house I was like oh she gonna get this
I'm letting no despite all
the child did to me
I still got in I mailed the
letter it came back a week
later I was like all this bitch to move
it again so she moves again never got
the letter she need for note so here it
is four years later I'm graduating from
college I get a call a week before my
graduation from my momma I don't know
where she was I didn't know how she knew
I was graduating all she wanted to do
was come and see me walk across the
stage and I'm thinking to myself oh you
gonna my graduation up but I can't
stop your hair from coming because you
know about it obviously so my mother
comes to the graduation I'm narrow my
dad my stepmom and I see her walking up
I hadn't already crossed the stage I'm
holding my degree I knew her ass was
coming and I had that
letter I had the letter I pulled out my
scrapbook I was like yeah
she gonna get this letter she gonna get
this letter so she steps
to me wanna hug me all this fake
and I'm just feelin it
so she hugging me oh let me take a
picture with you and your degree I was
like you could take pictures with me in
this letter and I gave her
ass that letter I did not take no bitch
where I was like that I am out of
here
and I left quickly because I knew my
momma opened that letter of while I was
standing there she will me up I
gave it I said I'll let you take a
picture with that all right you know now
that I'm letting y'all know right now
it's because of all the bad that
happened he made me the good
that I am today
[Applause]
be the catalyst in your life that's my
story I hope y'all enjoy